happy birthday thank you are we saying
the age we are yeah well yeah yeah 22
[Laughter]
for those kinds of twins we were born
before yeah now we are we turned 39 this
year yeah it's amazing how'd you guys
celebrate yesterday oh it was a big one
we took a flight from Vancouver to
Toronto but we upgraded the premium
economy always I had two glasses of
chardonnay nice I finished off almost an
entire giant size Pringles and sorry
have both a book and an album coming out
so what made it made it happen that you
want to do these two things at the same
time well we decided we wanted to do the
book and once it was sold and we started
writing we sort of went on a pilgrimage
of sorts and we went looking for
resource materials things to pull from
to write help us write the book and in
the process of gathering all these
photos and stories and interviewing
friends and family we found all this VHS
footage from the 90s so that's when we
were teenagers and we also ended up
finding a couple cassette tapes of our
first band and yeah just that further we
dug into the story the more we wrote and
the more I dug into all of these you
know songs I just I I kept thinking well
when we're done the book we're gonna
have to work on a new record and these
songs are so great I would love to learn
them and play them and maybe we play a
couple of them oh maybe we should put
out an EP and then it was like Sara
listen to the song so she loved them and
I thought is this her new record like
should we just take these songs and you
know like use all of our abilities like
reimagine them is 2019 or Tegan and Sara
but uh we just became obsessed with
making it into the new record so what
was supposed to be a year off turned
into writing a book and then it turned
into writing a book and making a record
well here we are like how much did you
have to change the songs like did you
like them all when you heard them again
you know there were songs that really
stood out and then there were others
where we would we would sort of you know
I know we would poach like a chorus we'd
be like oh that's a great part the rest
of the song but you know remarkably the
songs were a lot more fully formed and
sophisticated I think than we imagined
yes they were don't work they were
scrappy recordings and you know we
excellent guitar players or singers yet
but I think that the that the the vast
majority like the energy and like the
main melodies and the main themes and
lyrics we tried to really keep keep
those so that the music would feel
really like it was honoring that those
original demos but you know we did a bit
of surgery to make sure that they didn't
sound like we didn't let ourselves be
limited by the fact that these were some
of our first songs that we ever wrote we
have skills now and we have ideas now
that we felt we could like gently and
have them right now with the book you
guys write your own chapters like
separately why did you decide to do that
kind of write on your own there were a
bunch of different ideas that were sort
of thrown out or lobbed at us when we
were out selling the proposal and I
think for us the idea of keeping our
voice separate on the page was really
important because you know our music is
just under Tegan and Sara we don't make
a big deal out of whose song is whose
fans mouth but in general we share in
that and we have our voices sort of
weave together and instead of layering
them together in a chapter we thought
that we'd see the book itself almost as
a song and so you know the different
parts would be it'd be standalone and I
think Sara's experience in high school
was so uniquely different you know and I
think that's part of why we wanted to
write the book there's this
misconception that identical twins you
guys must have told each other everyone
we've been best friends and you can read
each other's minds and it's like no yeah
that's not how it is so I think it was
really important for us each to carve
out space for ourselves and write
independent of the other we also I think
we didn't realize how important and
special this would be but it's
fascinating to see where our memories
crossover oh yeah and also fascinating
to see where they just are so yep even
though we both experienced the same
thing we had such different impressions
of what happened and yeah it was we
write music separately so it just it was
very natural for us to carve out space
for ourselves within them yeah what did
you learn about each other from reading
the other person she's my sister yes I
[Laughter]
think overall you know the the sort of
the the sort of important discovery in
in reading each other's chapters and
sort of putting this book together was
that that there was so much that we
assumed that we knew about one another
and you know I think I obviously I had
my my my suspicions that Tekin was
having a seeker of a relationship with
her best friend because I had had a
secret relationship with my best friend
and you know sorry I sort of knew the
clues but I I didn't I didn't ask and I
didn't know and I think because then we
entered adulthood we sort of left all of
that that information and those stories
and those memories and those feelings
you know in our adolescence and to go
back and sort of really analyze it and
and and deconstruct it you know it gave
me a sense of sense a different sense of
Tegan and what her early seminal
experiences how that how that how they
informed her as an adult and vice versa
and I think it it allowed us to probably
understand why in our career we've had
these difficult times and why my
reactions to certain certain parts of
our career have been not negative but
I've I've had more I've been the
resistant one or I've been more
suspicious or I've been more hesitant
Egan was always like and it's so cute to
look back at her journals and see that
we were exactly the same we really were
sort of like dealing with these sort of
dualities even as teenagers and I think
there was something really it was easier
for me to be empathetic about well the
way Tegan is knowing that this is kind
of where the origin of that is from
right when you write something like this
that's so confessional
do you have to have conversations with
family friends like warn people like
we're other people in your life you're
like this is going to be in the book yes
I don't know if you have to warn people
we certainly did yes most of the people
we ended up writing about in the book
we're still very close with and we
wanted them to understand the purpose
behind the book you know it wasn't just
to tell our story it was to tell what we
thought was a really nuanced very
specific kind of story about having a
mom that went back to school and work
nights and you know having you know this
relationship to our stepdad and and and
you know him basically having to step in
and raise us and the lack of parents at
times and we wanted to make sure to put
in some of the stuff about our drug use
and how important that and significant
and seminal that was and there was a lot
that we wanted to put in there me one
give people fair warning to prepare
there was definitely some conversations
with friends whether it was like hi if
you haven't told your parents
pretty much everything we also were very
clear upfront with people this wasn't a
salacious tell-all this is about us this
is our impression this is us telling our
story and so if details didn't need to
be there we'd get rid of them we
certainly didn't want to put anyone on
blast we did a lot too you know I've
changed people's identities everyone in
the book has a pseudonym but you know to
give our friends and family major props
here the most of them signed releases to
have their photos included in the book
most have been included in you know
we've been doing interviews with them
have been a part of this process and so
it's a love story about not just like
about our relationship and and being
siblings who adored each other and made
music and have these tensions and our
first girlfriends and all these it's
also about this broader group of family
and friends who they were our first
audience they were the people who
supported us encouraged us I
these kids that we grew up with these
people that we write about in the book I
love these people they're still some of
the most significant people in my life
today and so the book as Tegan said it's
not a salacious tell-all it's not us
dragging people or bringing up people's
worst moments or worst memories in fact
it was just ours yeah we did bring up a
lot of difficult memories from our own
our own lives but the goal really here
was to protect as a strong word but like
I wanted to make sure that people
understood that this book was being
written from a place of love I look back
at that time now and feel such pride and
such I don't know not it's not nostalgia
but it's something it's very powerful
was very powerful time in our lives to
to discover our identity as queer women
but also his creative artists and to go
back and be able to look at that time
and also still have those significant
relationships that allowed us to be
those people I mean I have nothing but
love and respect for all of the people
that we wrote about in the book yeah is
there anything that you almost didn't
put in that you did include like was the
drug use because I was a pretty shocking
part of the book was that something that
you weren't gonna put in no I think you
know to it was like we dialed the drug
use
was almost 500 and some pages so and we
did four drafts of the book and so I
think that it took time to carve out
what we thought the most important story
was what the most important themes to
focus on were and I think in the end we
determined that sharing a bit about how
we had used and experimented with drugs
and alcohol was important because it
showcased how Sarah and I had used that
to open up when we were very closed and
we were very unhappy we were also very
like our relationship was fraught there
was a lot of anger and frustration and
disconnection between us and you know I
think often women are in society are
taught don't don't talk about those
things we're not allowed to have you
know three-dimensional lives we're not
allowed to make mistakes or experiment
or you know do these things and men are
sort of rewarded and celebrated and so I
think Sarah and I I think we're being
just I think we're being disruptors in a
way too I wanted that still part of the
story in there because this wasn't a
how-to and this isn't us encouraging
other people it's a different time and
different drugs out there but for us it
was an important part of the story it's
also important because music replaced it
right when we figured out that we could
write songs that we started to perform
for friends we became singularly focused
almost you know we started to dive into
who we were and use music to explain and
open up but drugs had been that for us
it'll you know and so we wanted to put
it in there but that's not gonna be for
everybody I don't think everyone's gonna
celebrate that and and but when we put
people in the public sphere on a
pedestal we're setting them up to fail
and I think for Sarah and I one of the
things that's kept us relevant in 20
years and also kept us real is that we
don't hide who we are and I think that
there are parts of our history our inner
we had homophobia internally we we were
you know out of control teenagers at
points like we grew into wonderful women
and and I think we are strong role
models and we are business owners and
we've been successful but pretending
like we didn't have a flawed pathway
it's ridiculous yeah and so yeah and I
think we do it in a respectful way and I
think people will really enjoy it and I
think it'll make people laugh and it'll
also make you think my goodness where
did all that acid come from in nine days
you